ande amable en la ciudad de maracay en
el estado aragua iraida cae la fiel
seguidora del chavismo se alista para
convencer a sus vecinos de salir a votar
en las elecciones regionales de este 21
de noviembre
que tenemos a un gobierno que nos está
ayudando a través del carné de la patria
y nos llegan bonos ayudas que compensan
ese poco dinero que nos entra a través
de los sueldos eso lo compensamos con
estos bonos todo bien
aquí estábamos el equipo de la comunidad
verdad se funda común
y esperamos que nos digas que si su
estado natal ha sido gobernado por el
chavismo durante 22 años y hoy los
ciudadanos sufren constantes apagones
eléctricos escasez de gasolina y gas
doméstico aún en estas circunstancias la
oposición no es opción para esta
chavista vendrían por nuestras cabezas
si lo harían si lo harían se acaban las
pensiones se acaban las clases se acaban
las misiones se acaba todo eso vamos a
caracas a katia un bastión oficialista
lilia en francia se aferra a fotos del
fallecido ex presidente hugo chávez como
quien venera un santo reconoce fallas
del gobierno socialista pero lo excusa
en el gobierno y falla pero tenemos
polica que el hombre que escogió hugo
rafael chávez frías que nicolás maduro
lo escogió para que él fuera el que
llevaba este timón que no es fácil a sol
ya sombra recorre calles toca puertas
ofrece asistencia con traslados para el
día de la elección no desfallece en su
afán de lograr el triunfo de su
candidato alcalde que ha prometido
progreso económico todo tiene que salir
a ayudar es devuelta a maracay iraida
visitó ya cinco casas en su balance dos
eran opositoras aunque dice logró
convencer las arrollar lo bueno según
encuestas entre 76 y 80 por ciento de
los venezolanos desea un cambio político
en el país pero la abstención y las
divisiones entre líderes opositores que
dispersan el voto reducen los chances de
triunfo en cualquier elección gracias mi
comandante póngame tanta fuerza